[Music]
on this Monday night the Prime Minister
pushes back Justin Trudeau stands by a
liberal MP accused of receiving support
from Beijing suggestions that he is
somehow not loyal to Canada
should not be entertained and defends
Canada's Democratic process
striking a deal at long last the
proposal to fix Northern Ireland's
post-brexit problems
that Storm's record-breaking snow and
tornadoes what in the end the brutal mix
of weather battering the U.S plus the
cosmic discovery's stunning career
chemists we think that NASA didn't know
about it Ottawa students move the needle
along keeping astronauts safe and
healthy
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
prime minister is standing by a liberal
MP whose sources have told Global News
is a winning affiliate in a Chinese
government interference Network Justin
Trudeau was asked today about a story
Global News broke about Han dong the MP
for Dawn Valley North sources within the
Canadian Security intelligence service
have told Global News the liberal party
was warned about Hong Dong's alleged
connection with the Chinese government
in advance of him being nominated as a
liberal candidate in 2019. hondong
himself rejects the allegations saying
they are inaccurate and irresponsible
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson has our top story tonight
prime minister Justin Trudeau praised
liberal Member of Parliament Han dong on
Monday in Toronto after the MP faced
explosive allegations connecting him to
a foreign interference Network reported
by global news let me say that we are
extraordinarily lucky
to have a member of parliament like Han
dong in our midst serving his community
Trudeau stood by the Ontario MP
dismissing any concerns about Dong I
want to make everyone understand fully
Han dong is an outstanding member of our
team
and suggestions that he is somehow not
loyal to Canada
should not be entertained on Friday
Global news's Sam Cooper reported that
intelligence sources allegedly
approached senior liberals during Dong's
writing nomination process to warn them
about Dong's alleged connections to the
Chinese government in a highly unusual
briefing a meeting that sources say was
scheduled two days before the nomination
deadline accelerated today the Prime
Minister skirted questions about whether
he or other senior liberals were warned
about Dong but said any suggestions
cesus directed the Liberals to rescind
Dong's nomination is not true Global
News did not suggest csis ordered the
Liberal Party to ax Dong's nomination
the suggestions we've seen in the media
that cecis would somehow say no this
person can't run or that person can't
run
is not just false it's actually damaging
to people's confidence in our Democratic
and political institutions Trudeau was
emphatic in saying no intelligence
briefing would dictate who parties
choose to run in a democracy it is not
up
to unelected
security officials to dictate to
political parties who can or cannot run
that's a really important principle dong
posted a statement on Twitter stating he
has the utmost regard for the Integrity
of Canada's Democratic institutions and
will refute what he called Anonymous and
unverified allegations saying I strongly
reject the insinuations in the media
reporting that allege I have played a
role in offshore interference in these
processes and will defend myself
vigorously against such inaccurate and
irresponsible claims that come from an
unverified and anonymous source dong
says he supports the Parliamentary
committee looking into foreign meddling
I will support all fact-based efforts
from parliamentarians to investigate
alleged offshore interference
all right Mercedes is with me now
Mercedes what about a public inquiry the
NDP leader judgment Singh has added his
voice to those who want one instead of
hearing from Anonymous sources and
leaked documents so will there be one
well that's the big question here and so
far we're not getting an answer that
sounds particularly positive from the
prime minister to move in that direction
he keeps citing the Parliamentary
committee that's in place but a number
of experts uh have suggested including a
former National Security adviser to
prime minister Trudeau that it's simply
two partisan of an environment in this
Parliament to really seriously get to
the bottom of something that deals with
significant classified information when
the Prime Minister was asked about what
his view was on calling an inquiry today
take a listen to what he had to say I
think it's a it's a really important and
great thing that Canadians are so
interested in ensuring that our
principles of democracy and our practice
of democracy
continues to be protected from the
ongoing interference as attempted by
authoritarian governments around the
world whether it be China or other
countries like it
so Donna no commitment from the prime
minister at this point despite growing
voices calling for it including as you
mentioned NDP leader jug meet Singh we
spoke to Peter Julian today who is an
NDP MP he says the NDP is not too
impressed with how the prime minister is
handling these allegations and that's
exactly why an inquiry is needed listen
to this it's seems to me that Mr Trudeau
is is not responding in the way that he
should as prime minister he should be
the first one stepping up and saying
these allegations are serious we need to
have a national public inquiry
Donna what I found remarkable is that
now some of prime minister Trudeau's
most trusted advisors including his
former principal secretary Jerry butts
and Bruce Anderson the pollster have
both stepped forward to say they believe
that an inquiry is the only way to get
to the bottom of this issue all right
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
the federal government is Banning the
video sharing platform Tick Tock from
all federal government devices the
government says after a review Canada's
Chief Information officer determined
tick tock's data collection presents an
unacceptable level of risk to privacy
and security on Wednesday The Tick Tock
app will be removed and blocked from all
government-issued mobile devices
certainly I suspect that as government
takes the significant step of telling
all federal employees that they can no
longer use to talk on their on their
work phones many Canadians from
businesses to private individuals will
reflect on the security of their own
data and perhaps make choices in
consequence
the U.S government put in place a
similar ban last year Tick Tock is owned
by Chinese parent company bite dance
Canada's privacy commissioner is
investigating whether Tick Tock complies
with Canadian privacy laws Israeli
settlers have attacked Palestinian
villages in the northern occupied West
Bank and according to Palestinian
authorities at least one man is dead
more than 100 injured
earning in Valley
Vandal in hundreds of vehicles it is
Revenge after two settlers were killed
by Palestinians on Saturday Israel has
moved in hundreds of extra troops on
Sunday Israeli and Palestinian security
officials met in Jordan for the first
high-level talks in years aimed at
calming tensions but the situation on
the ground is getting worse
Russia has launched a new wave of
iranian-made drones Ukraine's military
says it shot down 11 of the 14 drones
including nine targeting the capital
this video shows one of Russia's drone
strikes over Kiev soldiers used a
spotlight to scan the skies and shoot
down the drones Russian forces are
keeping up their attacks and are closing
in now in the city of bakmut in
Ukraine's Dawn bass region where both
sides are fighting for every inch of
territory Crystal gemancing Reports
Russia claims in the past 24 hours it's
killed 250 Ukrainian service members
around donask
no doubt many who end up at this field
hospital near buckmut are on the cusp
before The full-scale Invasion we had 50
to 60 wounded in a nine-month rotation
now sometimes we have more than that in
a day Russian separatists have
controlled part of the Donetsk region
since 2014. all of it now is contested
and ukrainians are fighting in close
proximity with invading forces
for two months Russia has been driving
to capture the eastern city of bakmut
Vladimir zielinski's office called it
the hottest spot on the entire front
line when he visited in December today
it is no less blistering
Ukraine is using infantry and artillery
to hold its ground but the full invasion
is bleeding the country economically as
well it's estimated the country needs up
to 57 billion dollars in financial
support
the U.S treasury secretary Janet Yellen
met with the president in Kiev handing
over the first transfer of 1.25 billion
dollars saying the money will keep
critical Services operating under
extraordinary circumstances attacks on
civilians and civilian infrastructure
have caused many casualties and terrible
sufferings the UN Human Rights
Commission is set to decide if the
Mandate of the investigative body
examining atrocities in Ukraine should
be extended Russia was suspended from
the unhrc in April but on Thursday the
deputy foreign minister will address the
committee
Crystal commencing Global News London
almost seven years after the UK voted to
leave the European Union a festering
dispute over trade rules for Northern
Ireland appears to finally be resolved
Britain and the EU have reached a deal
over the politically sensitive land
border crossing between Ireland and
Northern Ireland Redmond Shannon
explains what the deal means and why it
matters
an audience with King Charles for the
European commission president Ursula Van
Der Lyon despite the Monarch being above
politics these pictures are perhaps part
of the process to mend a relationship
shredded by brexit this new framework
will allow us to begin a new chapter the
new post-brexit proposal is designed to
tweak the status of Northern Ireland
after an older deal brokered under
former British prime minister Boris
Johnson under those terms the UK
territory effectively remained inside
the EU for trade to keep its land border
with the Republic of Ireland open that
means some customs checks take place on
trade into Northern Ireland from the
rest of the UK it also gave the European
court of justice jurisdiction in
Northern Ireland unacceptable to
pro-british unionists there who have
boycotted Northern Ireland's Parliament
prime minister Rishi sunak says the New
Deal fixes the issues we can now say
that Goods will throw freely smoothly
across the UK internal Market that we've
protected Northern Ireland's place in
our Union The Joint news conference
remarkable in its warmth and positivity
after years of verbal darts across the
English Channel we also both knew their
regime that we could do it the details
are complex nailed down without the
pressure of the hard deadline like in
2020. serious thought about stuff
talking to people in a reasonable way
rather than using a loud healer actually
works that's why I think this is a very
significant moment MPS including sunax
Hardline Tories and the skeptical
Northern Irish unionists will now take
time to consider the deal before voting
on it whatever happens next the scars of
the continent's messy divorce appear to
be healing Donna okay Redmond Shannon in
London thanks a stormy situation in the
U.S coming up the severe weather systems
Rick Havoc Across America plus stepping
down Canada soccer's president Baus
public pressure
the president of Canada's soccer the
sports governing body has resigned Nick
bontes says there is potential for the
national men's and women's teams to sign
new Collective agreements but he says
the moment requires change at the top
both national teams had called for a
change in leadership and 13 provincial
and territorial soccer federations had
also called on him to step down
tonight parts of Southern Ontario and
Quebec are under winter weather warnings
bracing for more Fierce wind freezing
rain and snow extreme cold is expected
in Newfoundland and Labrador as well
South of the Border powerful storms are
bringing everything from heavy snow to
mudslides even tornadoes from California
to Michigan some 250 thousand homes and
businesses are still without power as
Jackson prosco reports even more wild
weather is forecast
what in the world is that unusual in its
timing and ferocity
this February outbreak of violent
weather saw at least eight tornadoes
touch down in Oklahoma alone a record
for the month we heard two large thumps
and then the moment we heard that my
daughter covered her head in her back
window busted out behind her head more
than a dozen people were injured in the
city of Norman Oklahoma
Witnesses say the storms came on
suddenly and there was little time to
prepare all of a sudden it like felt
like
like a bomb here outside or something
the whole house kind of shifted in the
garage move entire neighborhoods were
decimated with cars tossed around like
toys and buildings shredded by the
Ferocious wind look at all those horses
and they're okay
wow roofs were ripped clean off of
buildings leaving only walls behind
elsewhere the storms brought golf
ball-sized hail
in parts of Texas and New Mexico gritty
dust storms swept across the plains
along with howling wind gusts topped 160
kilometers per hour
in California that same system blanketed
the mountains in historic amounts of
snow more powder than New York has seen
all winter never seen this much snow
come down this long this hard
since 31 years more than two meters of
snow fell over the weekend with whiteout
conditions expected in the coming days
Yosemite National Park is closed until
at least Wednesday all of it a wild
closing act in the last month of this
topsy-turvy winter a season that
shattered records and expectations
Jackson prosco Global News
[Music]
full intelligence could help
Alberta is the latest Province to have
signed on to the federal government's
Health Care funding deal Alberta will
get more than 24 billion dollars for its
Health Care system over the next 10
years that includes an immediate 233
million dollar Top-Up to the Canada
Health transfer to address urgent needs
Alberta is a seventh Province to sign
the agreement in principle with Ottawa
British Columbia Saskatchewan Quebec and
the territories have yet to reach a deal
researchers in Alberta have a new tool
which could help doctors better predict
which patients might have adverse
outcomes if they are prescribed opioids
the new predictive model uses artificial
intelligence Catherine Ward explains how
it works and how it could be applied to
patients
I literally did almost fall out of my
chair I I was pleased we didn't expect
it to to work crystal balls do not exist
when it comes to medicine but machine
learning might be the next best thing AI
can really be thought of
um as a prediction tool and that's
that's essentially what we're trying to
do right now is we're trying to make
predictions for two years researchers in
Alberta created a model tracking data
already being collected about opioid
prescriptions and Adverse Events they
looked at anonymized records for more
than 853 000 albertans in 2018 and 2019
in that span more than 6.1 million
opioid prescriptions were filled and
that same time more than 77 000 Adverse
Events were reported the patients who
end up going to emergency departments
who end up getting hospitalized as well
as who died so there's mortality data
discharge data the model was able to
follow Trends and with roughly 90
accuracy could predict someone's risk of
being hospitalized within 30 days of of
getting an opioid so we know that
opioids are high risk medications they
are necessary and essential medications
instead they hope the model is another
screening tool that can improve patient
care this is another decisioning that a
clinician can use to take care or to
maybe alter the types of medications
offered to maybe look for Alternatives
experts say it's only the beginning when
it comes to seeing how technology like
this can be leveraged the horse is out
at the barn with the applications of AI
in in the healthcare space just as in
other other areas I think we would be
doing ourselves an injustice not
capitalizing on the opportunity here and
using this methodology within Healthcare
as well researchers say the next phase
is to figure out what's needed to
implement the tool more widely so
doctors can access the model how that
will work exactly is still under
evaluation Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
send it to space Nancy Elementary School
students who help NASA make a
groundbreaking discovery
[Music]
a group of elementary school students in
Ottawa has made a remarkable Discovery
they sent an EpiPen into space as part
of a NASA experiment the point was to
find out if the pen that treats
potentially fatal allergies would work
in space what they learned not only
impressed scientists it has real
implications for astronaut safety turia
isri explains what do we need to get
done next for cubes in space in this
Ottawa science class the sky is not the
limit it's the starting point can you
just put your computers in politeness
mode for a moment these grade four to
six students at Saint brother Andre
Elementary School are in a gifted
program send two different things like a
vial of it with water and then like a
vial of it with like Damron around it
they're part of a NASA research
initiative helping kids launch
experiments in space and these 9 to 11
year olds are thinking way outside the
box to find out that scientists that
have been working for years and years
and years on this haven't discovered
something and then
us elementary school kids discover it
it's really cool the discovery began
with a common medical tool found in
schools across the country the EpiPen an
injectable device that delivers a
life-saving drug and reverses the
effects of severe allergies the students
had a question would an EpiPen still
work in space it was pretty cool because
we think that NASA didn't know about it
they put samples in tiny cubes sent on
board a NASA rocket and balloon once the
cubes returned to Earth their contents
were brought here to the University of
Ottawa where scientists made a
remarkable Discovery in the lab the
first part of doing science is asking
the right question and they asked a
fantastic question the answer stunned
career chemists
no longer worked
came poisonous there's an interaction
with the cosmic radiation that comes
when you leave the atmosphere we were
just like hide in the background ground
just being just smiling at each other
and be like yes
next the students will travel to
Virginia in June and present their
findings to NASA the students are very
forward-thinking they're already
anticipating people going to the moon
and then beyond and colonizing Mars
they're also eyeing careers in rocket
science you feel like you're making a
real change because a lot of the times
it feels like it's just adults and all
the molecules High achievers with
curiosity that knows no bounds
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
amazing stuff that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your candidate is the 50-point
conservation area in Hamilton Ontario
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you